people of the internet and hogwarts
legacy fans from around the world i want
to take you guys back let's use our time
turners here and go back just a little
bit in time just a few months ago to
march of 2022 we were practically
begging for news guys i mean we were
scraping by with any little
morsel of information about hogwarts
legacy and then
march 14th came and playstation dropped
this announcement we got the state of
play an incredible amount of information
was dropped there and then ever since
hogwarts legacy the folks at wb the
folks at avalanche have just been doing
a fantastic job i mean look at these
tweets here just a steady stream of
nothing too crazy but just some nice
little info to keep that excitement
going as we hopefully move towards even
more which more on that here in a second
the big one that i want to talk about
today though is if you scroll all the
way up here to may 13th now i know you
guys have probably already seen these at
this point but there's a lot that i want
to talk about here especially the
significance of these house patches why
would they decide to share these house
patches exactly well first of all i
think they look incredible if you look
at the tweet here designing iconic house
badges for hogwarts legacy was no easy
task which of our new house patches is
your favorite we're going to take a look
at them one by one here
gryffindor as you guys know i'm a
gryffindor i love the gryffindor one
kind of like the gryffindor common room
for me though i mean this one you're
playing it safe
nothing really too crazy here i love the
colors i think they they pop just right
everything looks good nothing you know
out of this world amazing nothing bad
very solid across the board though just
like the common rooms i mean they've
done a phenomenal job with these the
attention to detail that they are
showing with
seemingly everything surrounding this
game guys i mean it's truly exciting it
really is so let's jump onto the next
one here hufflepuff again i love the
hufflepuff one like the hufflepuff
common room i love how the badgers kind
of turning back again they nail the
colors uh the detail the stitching on
this is just great and so i i just love
the little pose that the badgers in i
think that's what really kind of makes
this one how he's turning around there
going to the next one here ravenclaw is
probably my favorite i think they did a
phenomenal job with the ravenclaw i just
love how the wings of the eagle by the
way not the raven guys the eagle i love
how the wings are spread out like that
got the little talons down here and
again the colors bronze and blue they
got it right guys not
silver so bronze and blue you love to
see it and then finally we have
slytherin which again slytherin i kind
of feel the sabot is gryffindor very
solid
like it nothing too crazy
i do again like the the pose here
similar to the badger i like kind of the
pose of that the snake's in and clearly
it's you know in the in the shape of an
s here so across the board though
i love the attention to detail with
these patches but i am left to wonder
why
share this and where exactly are these
going to be used sure we're probably
going to see them in game we can even
hop back right here and take a look at
the trailer and see that yes in fact
they are the very same designs that
they're using in game but this to me
these screenshots that we look at right
here i mean this looks like an actual
patch that you can buy or purchase now
if you look at the follow-up tweet
because there was a follow-up tweet to
this one you can also find these house
patches and the hogwarts legacy discord
as emotes and name badges when you
choose your house
so maybe i'm looking too far into this
but i don't think that is the only use
of these things guys i don't think that
is it i think these look
too intricately designed to just be a
digital
asset
i think and this is just a theory maybe
it's just someone even say a hope or a
dream i think these are going to be
featured in a collector's edition of
some sort i keep seeing that question
pop up a lot on twitter people ask me
hey have you heard anything about a
collector's edition i have heard nothing
i do have a video up on the channel kind
of exploring what i would like to be in
there expecto go recently had another
video that kind of reignited some
conversation around this
people want a collector's edition and i
i think avalanche knows this wb has to
know this
i feel it's almost a guarantee that
we're going to get a collector's edition
and i would love to see something like
these house patches in that collector's
edition whether it's on i don't know
maybe i kind of like the idea of having
the patches themselves so then you can
decide what to put them on but maybe
they're on you could put them on a shirt
you could put them in a hat you could
put them on a backpack lots of different
things
a bag like a satchel i could see that
but again to me these are just too
intricately designed to only be an
in-game digital thing i think they're
going to show up somewhere else now i
mentioned
more news potentially coming soon i know
about the asmr video we're going to have
a video up on that very very soon i
promise you guys i really want to break
that one down so we also just got more
news today i'm recording this the
evening of may 19th and today earlier
this day chandler wood the community
manager of hogwarts legacy tweeted this
right here can't believe it's already
been two months since the state of play
i'm really excited about what we're
working on right now we've got some
pretty cool stuff to show you later this
summer now i know there's been a lot of
rumors going around about a potential
delay for hogwarts legacy
i think that is just going to come with
the territory guys anytime there's a big
game and you start to see games like
star field getting delayed i mean we
really see this every year it's going to
happen it can happen to games could it
happen hogwarts legacy sure but
everything we have seen from avalanche
from wb seems that they are full steam
ahead on this everything seems to be
progressing nicely we are finally
getting that slow trickle of information
that we have been begging for and they
are keeping the excitement alive you
love to see this and of course now
everyone's going to be dissecting what
does he mean exactly by later this
summer well it could be you know two
weeks later could be around the time of
the summer game fest fester could be
more toward the end of summer that
remains to be seen as we know e3 is not
happening this year summer game fest is
happening regardless it is so awesome to
see that we are finally getting steady
information about hogwarts like z let me
know what you think about the patches in
the comments below and as soon as i have
that asmr video breakdown ready it'll be
on the right side of your screen which
you can click now
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon